can you maybe elaborate how the
principle of computational equivalence
can save
a planet
that would that would be a have a
terrible spoiler for that would be a
spoiler okay yeah yeah but but no but
let me say what the principle of
computational equivalence is
um
so the question is
you are
you have a system you have some rule
you can think of its behavior as
corresponding to a computation
the question is how sophisticated is
that computation
the statement of the principle of
computational equivalence is as soon as
it's it's not obviously simple it will
be as sophisticated as anything and so
that has the implication that you know
rule 30 uh you know our brains
other things in physics they're all
ultimately equivalent in the
computations they can do and that's what
leads to this computational
irreducibility idea because the reason
we don't get to jump ahead you know and
out think rule 30 is because we're just
computationally equivalent to rule 30 so
we're kind of just both just running
computations that are the same sort of
raw the same level of computation so to
speak so that's kind of the the idea
there and the question i mean it's it's
like uh the you know in in the science
fiction version would be okay somebody
says we just need more servers get us
more servers the way to get even more
servers is turn the whole planet into a
bunch of micro servers
and that that's uh that's where it
starts and so the question of you know
computational equivalence principle of
computational equivalence is well
actually you don't need to build those
custom servers actually you can
uh you can just um use natural
computation
to compute things so to speak you can
use nature to compute you don't need to
have done all that engineering and it's
kind of the it's kind of feels a little
disappointing that you say we're going
to build all these servers we're going
to do all these things we're going to
make you know maybe we're going to have
human consciousness uploaded into you
know some elaborate digital environment
and then you look at that thing and you
say it's got electrons moving around
just like in a rock
and then you say well what's the
difference and the principle of
computational equivalence says there
isn't at some level a fundamental you
know you can't say mathematically
there's a fundamental difference between
the rock that is the future of human
consciousness and the rock that's just a
rock
now what i've sort of realized with this
kind of consciousness thing is there is
a there is an aspect of this that seems
to be more special that isn't and and
for example something i i haven't really
teased apart properly is when it comes
to something like the weather and the
weather having a mind of its own or
whatever or your average you know pulsar
magnetosphere acting like a sort of
intelligent thing how does that relate
to you know how how do how is that
that entity related to the kind of
consciousness that we have and sort of
what would the world look like you know
to the weather if we think about the
weather as a mind
what will it perceive what will it laws
its laws of physics be i don't really
know
because it's very parallel it's very
parallel among other things and it it's
not obvious i mean this is a a really
kind of mind-bending thing because we've
got to try and imagine
where
uh you know we've got to try and imagine
a parsing of the universe different from
the one we have and by the way when we
think about extraterrestrial
intelligence and so on i think that's
kind of the key thing is you know we've
always assumed i've always assumed okay
the extraterrestrials at least they have
the same physics we all live in the same
universe they've got the same physics
but actually that's not really right
because the extraterrestrials could have
a completely different way of parsing
that the universe so it's as if you know
there could be for all we know right
here in this room you know in the in the
details of the motion of these gas
molecules there could be an amazing
intelligence that we were like but we
have no way of we're not parsing the
universe in the same way if only we
could parse the universe in the right
way you know immediately this amazing
thing that's going on and this you know
huge culture that's developed and all
that kind of thing would be obvious to
us but it's not because we have our
particular way of passing the universe
would that thing also have an
agency i don't know the right word to
use but something like consciousness but
a different kind of consciousness
i think it's a question of just what you
mean by the word because i think that
the you know this notion of
consciousness and the okay so some
people think of consciousness as sort of
a key aspect of it is that we feel
that
the the sort of a feeling of that we
exist in some way that we have this
intrinsic feeling about ourselves
you know i i suspect that any of these
things would also have an intrinsic
feeling about themselves i've been sort
of trying to think recently about
constructing an experiment about what if
you were just a piece of a cellular
automaton let's say you know what would
your feeling about yourself actually be
and you know can we put ourselves in the
in the shoes in the cells of the
cellular automaton so to speak can we
can we get ourselves close enough to
that that we could have a sense of what
the world would be like if you were
operating in that way and it's a little
difficult because you know you have to
not only think about what are you
perceiving but also what's actually
going on in your brain and our brains do
what they actually do and they don't
it's you know i think there might be
some experiments that are possible with
with uh you know neural nets and so on
where you can have something where you
can at least see in detail what's
happening inside the system and i i've
been sort of one of the one of my
projects to think about is is there a
way of kind of uh
kind of getting a sense kind of from
inside the system about what its view of
the world is and and how it how it you
know can can we make a bridge see the
main issue is this
where you know it's a it's a sort of
philosophically difficult thing because
it's like we do what we do we understand
ourselves um at least to some extent we
humans understand ourselves that's
correct and but yet okay so what are we
trying to do for example when we are
trying to make a model of physics what
are we actually trying to do because you
know you say well can we work out what
the universe does
well of course we can we just watch the
universe the universe does what it does
but what we're trying to do when we make
a model of physics is we're trying to
get to the point where we can tell a
story to ourselves that we understand
that is also a representation of what
the universe does
so it's this kind of you know can we
make a bridge between what we humans can
understand in our minds and what the
universe does
and in a sense you know a large part of
my kind of life uh efforts have been
devoted to making computational language
which kind of is a bridge between what
is possible in the computational
universe and what we humans can
conceptualize and think about in a sense
what you know when i built wolfram
language and our whole sort of
computational language story it's all
about how do you take sort of raw
computation and this ocean of
computational possibility and how do we
sort of represent pieces of it in a way
that we humans can understand and that
map on to things that we care about
doing and in a sense when you add
physics you're adding this other piece
where we can you know mediate it by
computer can we get physics to the point
where we humans can understand something
about what's happening in it
and when we talk about an alien
intelligence it's kind of the same story
it's like is there a way of mapping
what's happening there onto something
that we humans can understand and you
know physics in some sense is like
our exhibit one of the story of alien
intelligence it's it's a it's a you know
it's an alien intelligence in some sense
and what we're doing in making a model
of physics is mapping that onto
something that we understand and i think
you know a lot of these other things
that have i've recently been kind of
studying uh whether it's molecular
biology other kinds of things um which
we can talk about a bit um the um
those are other cases where we're in a
sense trying to again make that bridge
between what we humans understand and
sort of the the natural language of that
sort of alien intelligence in some sense
you